good afternoon and welcome to today's
College readout on the beam semester
packets or spring packages which the
college adopted today I have the
pleasure of having me vice-president
Dombrowski's Commissioner Tyson and
Commissioner Muscovy see they will give
you an introduction of what the college
spoke about today and we will then be
ready to take your questions
good afternoon everyone
indeed as Anika just said we spoke today
mostly on spring 2019 European semester
package but before giving in details on
this I will tell you quickly about two
other points which we had on agenda
today so first today the Commission has
adopted the EU s draft budget for 2020
we have proposed 168 point 3 billion
euros for 2020 for a more competitive
European economy and for solidarity and
security in the EU and beyond this
budget is a seventh and last ones under
the current 2014-2020 multi-annual EU
budget it's designed to optimize funding
for existing programs as well as new
initiatives and boost European added
value in line with the inker
commission's priorities the budget for
2020 has identified following priority
areas competitive economy and young
people strengthening security and
solidarity in the u climate change and
several others for example 21 percent of
the overall proposed budget for 2020
will go to tackle climate change this
alliance is a ambitious target of
spending 20% of EU s current multi
annual budget on activities that address
climate change
so our colleague günther Oettinger will
address European Parliament on this
topic this afternoon
jointly with members of European
Parliament or three oh my and Monica and
I will have a press conference today at
2:45 in front of the meeting room SP 5g
C we also heard from first Iceland first
vice president Timmerman's who informed
us about ongoing legislative files that
could still be delivered before the end
of the mandate of this commission
altogether this commission has made 474
legislative proposals which includes 44
proposed was presented by previous
commission of these 351 proposals have
been adopted or agreed by European
Parliament and or Council during the
present Monday this means that 167
proposals remain to be agreed at this
point and we estimate about half of
those have a chance of agreement before
31st of October so the college decided
to work hard until the very last strand
of this mandate to get our proposals
adopted and this brings me now to the
European semester this is a last spring
package for this commission so maybe
it's a chance to take stock of how far
we have come
the European economy is in much better
shape than when we found it seven years
of uninterrupted growth investment is
recovering public finances are improving
employment is at record levels some
twelve point six million jobs have been
created since 2014 and this is
widespread in in spite of the recent
slowdown and increased risks all EU
countries are set to grow this year and
into the next it shows that our economic
policies boosting investment stepping up
structural reforms and conducing
responsible fiscal policies that
a set of policies is working but
unfortunately it's not the case across
all Member States some member states
have not used the good economic times to
build fiscal buffers and implement
necessary reforms and there is still
much to do to make our economies more
competitive and resilient for all member
states new challenges lie ahead we need
to transform our economies to make sure
digitization population aging and
transition to the climate natural
economy don't undermine our strong
European social model in the indeed
making growth inclusive has been our
focus for several years so that it also
benefits everyone including the most
vulnerable this strong social dimension
is to be maintained
Maryanne will talk more on this and let
me point to two novelties in this year's
country specific recommendations first a
greater focus on investment a dedicated
country specific recommendation
identifies priority investment needs for
each country be it for private or public
investments we stay special we pay
special attention to addressing regional
and territorial disparities and as in
these investment needs should be
addressed by public and private sources
including EU EU funding second for
several countries namely Bulgaria
Denmark Estonia Latvia Malta and Sweden
we propose country specific
recommendations in relations to anti
money laundering
failure to address shortcomings in AML
enforcement can seriously undermine in
confidence in European banking sector
this is why it's European problem and we
must work on it as such today we also
adopted a number of fiscal decisions as
well as report under enhanced
surveillance for Greece Pierre will
elaborate
on those cases so let me say just a few
words for three countries Spain Italy
and Greece today we are proposing to
abrogate excessive deficit procedure for
Spain so let me congratulate Spain
of course the logic of stability and
respect is that a Spain like other
member states must continue to focus on
sound public finances precisely to avoid
problems in the future as of this year
Spain will be in the preventive arm of
the pact which means that we will look
at the illusion of depth and the
delivery of the required structural
effort which is expected to be at 0.65
percent of GDP this year and also next
on Italy today we have published a
report under article 1 26.3 of the
treaty assessing the breach of the depth
benchmark in 2018 it concludes that the
depth criterion is not complied with and
that depth based a excessive deficit
procedure is thus warranted to be a
clear today we are not opening the
excessive deficit procedure first EU
member states how to give their views on
the article 126 3 report the economic
and financial committee has two weeks to
formulate its opinion on our conclusions
but it's much more than just about the
procedure when we look at the Italian
economy we are seeing the damage recent
policy choices are doing let me give you
some examples we estimate that interest
expenditure for Italy in 2018 turned out
to be higher bra by around 2.2 billion
euros if we compare with our spring
forecast this is a talk about 2018
spring forecast today Italy pace in
depth servicing as much as for the
entire education system in 2018 Italy's
depth represented an average burden of
thirty eight thousand four hundred euros
per inhabitant and in addition the
average depth servicing cost per person
was around one thousand euros gross has
come to almost a halt as a heap to
confidence and higher interest rates how
aggregated the impact of external
factors such as global trade tensions or
general slowdown in the world economy we
now expects a Italian depth ratio to
raise in both 2019 and 2020 up to 135
percent of GDP due to the gap between
interest rates and growth rates or
so-called snowball effect but also due
to declining primary surplus and
underachieved privatization precedes we
know that there is a path for recovery
and growth to Italy other member states
have already taken it with success this
path follows a renewed reform effort and
not spending more when there is no
fiscal space to do so let me also say a
few words on Greece during this
Commission's mandate Greece is amongst
those countries as how implemented most
reforms
thanks to those reforms and some thanks
to sound fiscal policies the country is
on a path of recovery with growing
employment and consumer demand in April
following the implementation of specific
commitments Europe released the first
tranche of post-second policy
contingents depth measures however the
reform momentum has slowed in recent
months in May Greece adopted a series of
expansionary fiscal measures and
announced more for later today support
notes that the packages are costly and
does not go in right policy direction it
under some elements of important past
programme reforms and these new measures
pose risks to achievement of the agreed
primary surface target of sahar percent
of GDP this year and beyond to conclude
it's important not to
the major progress made in recent years
it is a delicate exercise for Greece to
return to the market so is public depth
of around 180 percent of GDP there is
very little room for mistakes thank you
good afternoon
we've just adopted the last spring
package under this Commission including
country specific recommendations and a
number of reports and important fiscal
decisions and in doing this we are
assuming our responsibilities in full
right to the end of our mandate and we
remain true to our initial mission of
support for growth job creation and the
need for sound public finances there are
three messages from today's package
first of all some good news it's the end
of the EDP cycle a cycle that started
under the financial crisis the time has
come today to bring to a close the last
of these procedures the one for Spain
which was opened 10 years ago let me
remind you in 2011 24 member states were
covered by this procedure and when the
Commission this Commission took up
office in November 2014 there was still
11 under the procedure so I would also
like to express my congratulations
to Spain your hard work has borne fruit
although we know that problems remain in
particular in relation to unemployment
but this basically marks the end of a
long and difficult road not just for
Spain but for the whole of the European
Union and the eurozone and the decision
to abrogate taken by the Commission
today is a reflection of Spain's efforts
and we would encourage Spain to remain
committed to sound public finances the
second important message is as follows
through this package we continue to
offer economic and fiscal guidance to
member states to
your coordination between our economies
and to make a stronger both individually
and collectively there are targeted
recommendations which focus on the
specific priorities faced by individual
member states in order to improve growth
to create jobs unemployment is still an
issue and also to ensure sustainable
development which is a challenge for the
future all those elements can be found
in this package and in spring next year
the next commission in picking up the
baton will have to ensure the proper
implementation of these recommendations
today let me say once again that we are
also trying to correct certain practices
that are detrimental to our economies
and to our society for example fighting
money-laundering in Denmark Estonia
Latvia Bulgaria Malta and Sweden
measures to preserve the independence of
the judiciary and the rule of law in
Cyprus and Hungary and efforts to combat
aggressive tax planning in Cyprus
Hungary Ireland Luxembourg Malta and the
Netherlands this is a matter close to my
heart the whole question of aggressive
tax planning in line with the eurozone
recommendation for the first time we've
come forward with a specific
recommendation for those member states
who have been identified on the basis of
an in-depth examination of fiscal rules
relevance economic indicators and
specific country analysis progress
varies there is more progress in some
countries than others for example
Ireland's and Netherlands and the
Netherlands are very much on the right
track but progress is still necessary
and we want to encourage countries along
that path and the third important
message from today is that today we are
assuming our responsibilities as visa
vie a number of countries who have to
face very difficult but different
circumstances and this requires the
intelligent but serious application of
our shared rules first of all for Greece
this morning we adopted the third
enhanced surveillance report for Greece
as you know these quarterly reports
allow us to monitor the respect of
agreed fiscal targets and the
implementation of reform measures Greece
let me say once again has started this
new post program chapter in a positive
way overall with important success for
example there was a budgetary surplus
for the third consecutive year in 2018
Greece has gradually returned to the
markets I know that this is a pending
objective for Greece and there have been
other additional measures to the tune of
970 million euros which were implemented
in April so a lot has been done by the
Greek authorities to revive the Greek
economy and I wanted to make that point
clear
however in our report we've also
identified a number of delays in
implementing reform commitments and
we've also highlighted the risks in
relation to the fulfilment of fiscal
targets following the package of
measures adopted last month we need to
be very aware of the effect of these
measures over the next few months and we
need to look at the figures to be
achieved in order to achieve cruising
speed the Commission will continue to
help Greece to return to sustainable
economic revival and we intend to pursue
the constructive dialogue that we have
had with the Greek authorities over the
last few years
moving on to Hungary and Romania Hungary
and Romania have adopted an expansionist
policy rather than streamlining their
public
finances in a favorable economic
environment a very favorable economic
environment in fact because previous
recommendations have not been respected
we will recommend to council the
following no effective measures have
been adopted and therefore a procedure
for significant deviation should be
renewed for these two countries and this
procedure would apply for 2019 and 2020
with an annual effort of 1% and not 0.7%
of respectively for four member states
we adopted reports based on article 1 to
6 3 of the treaty this looks into
reasons for the non respect of debt and
deficit criteria either individually or
together these countries are Italy
Belgium France and Cyprus in all cases
there has been non respect of these
criterias either separately or combined
and the analysis takes this into account
for 2019 and 2020 as well as other
relevant factors for France we have
concluded that the two criteria have
been respected when it comes to the
deficit there has been an overshoot of
the 3% limit that's forecast for 2019
but this will be a limited overshoot 3.1
percent and temporary in nature it will
last for one year and this increase is
due to the replacement of the CIC II the
competitiveness employment tax credits
which was adopted when I was finance
minister in fact and this has been
replaced by a reduction in perennial
contributions this will have a one-off
impact to the tune of not 0.9% in 2019
as of 2020 according to our forecasts
the deficits will fall back well below
3% down to two point two percents and
when it comes to the debt the debt I
believe has to be reduced but overall
Frances risk
effect of the preventive arm has the is
deemed to be a relevant relevant grounds
for not opening a procedure when it
comes to Belgium this is a borderline
case as we say he's difficult to say
definitively the structural balance was
neutral in 2018 and it's likely to
remain so in 2019 although it should be
improving and yet at the same time debt
is going down gradually and the nominal
deficit will remain well below 3% 1.3
percent for this year according to our
forecast so these are positive
developments which offset the concerns
we have about the structural balance for
2018 and 2019 so no procedure our report
was triggered by the fact that the
airline deficit reached four point eight
percent of GDP in 2018
however this was entirely due to banking
support measures which were necessary to
preserve financial stability in Cyprus
moreover for both this year and 2020 we
forecast a significant budgetary Serpas
and also strongly declining public debt
we are thus decided against opening an
EDP given that no further adjustment is
needed and a procedure would add little
value and would appear a trick control
intuitive to citizens let's not be too
formal
this wouldn't have made any sense as
regards
Italy now the figures have been given by
for this I will say that they are
problematic on two fronts
instead of being reduced Italy's public
debt which is a major burden on the
economy increased further from one
hundred and thirty one percent to one
hundred and thirty two percent of GDP
and second problems approached the
structural deficit with
should have declined by the 0.3%
according to the counsel recommendation
instead widened by a 0.8% meaning there
was a gap of 0.4 percent percentage
points this is for 2018 I recall that
unfortunately also for 2019 we focused a
slight worsening in the structural
deficit whereas council has recommended
a reduction of 0.6% and the internal
authorities had made a commitment last
December to avoid any deterioration and
finally for 2020 we forecast a large
increase in the deficit both in
structural and nominal terms to 3.5% of
GDP well above the treaty threshold on
this basis and having examined all
relevant factors we have concluded that
debt criterion is currently not
respected and that that based excessive
deficit procedure is warranted for Italy
let's be clear we're not opening today
this EDP it is now for the council to
express its views on this objective and
on our analysis which is purely factual
pending this opinion I see no need to
speculate further at this stage neither
in the mindset leader markets of course
as always with all Member States we are
ready to look a new data that could
change this analysis so la mía porta
Romani aperto and for those who don't
understand
my Italian forgive them I would say my
door is opened the pot a bit new rule
we're happy to discuss and listen to
what you have to say a cage of our
mandate we are presenting I think
current set of recommendations to build
on what we have achieved in these past
five years and to tackle the major
economic and also societal changes
Europe is set to face in the coming
years in particular we reaffirmed today
our commitment to an intelligent
application of the instability and
respect that means basing our decisions
not on a mechanistic or legalistic or
purely mechanistic or legalistic
application of the rules but on whether
they are good for growth job and sound
public finances thank you for your
attention and over to good good morning
ladies and gentlemen
the real novelty of this year's European
semester exercise is that we deepen our
focus on investment by identifying
investment priorities for each member
state we operationalize how we want to
streamline the use of the European funds
many of these investment priorities can
and will be supported by the cohesion
funds for 2021 to 2027 and it is clear
that that support can of course not
cover everything but we are forcefully
moving towards a stronger link between
the European semester and the funding so
that a part of the European budget is
used to support the reforms we have
agreed with member states
today's country with specific
recommendations allow us to focus on the
main issues that need further attention
and almost half of them address labor
market and Social Affairs a further sign
of how social the semester has become I
would like to focus on five key issues
we have identified first employment
including quality of employment
even though employment is at a record
level we see large differences between
countries regions and population groups
some regions are left behind temporary
and the
a typical work is disturbingly frequent
in some countries and in work poverty is
increasing the second one is about
social protection the rise of
non-standard work and self-employment
forces us to rethink how we make sure
all people in work are adequately
covered an erosion of social protection
leaves workers insufficiently protected
and our social security poorer then
there is also the rapidly changing world
of work that demands from us to adapt
and to innovate investing in people is
key for sustainable and inclusive growth
but we also need to address inequalities
in education and training and everybody
must have equal access to quality
education this includes lifelong
learning for adults otherwise we
endanger the long-term prosperity of our
societies and then we have of course
another challenge that's the aging
societies with those ageing of the
population sustainability of pensions
and health care also long-term care
require a hard thing we must ensure
positive reforms are not retracted costs
don't believe at intergenerational
fairness is maintained and that finally
equality between men and women
this keeps improving but with the
persisting gender pay gap and employment
gap and this is shows that it's clear
that we are not yet there the new rules
on work-life balance of course they are
a milestone that can help to improve the
situation but member states need to
implement this on the ground and to
complement it threat affordable and
quality childcare and long term care
facilities while there is work to do we
have built a stable ground on which the
next commission can continue this effort
the employment and social outlook and
Europe is developing in the right
direction with still record levels of
employment with now 241 million people
in jobs in the
Union employment is at 6.4% April this
year this is now below the lowest point
attained before the crisis the
improvement is even more remarkable for
young people with an unemployment rate
went from a peak of almost 24% in spring
2013 to 14.2% today and poverty and
social exclusion are going down this
shows that our policies are bearing
fruit the European pillar of social
rights of course is crucial to continue
delivering it is the basis for all
future policies and investment
priorities for improving working and
living conditions across the European
Union our recommendations today those we
adopted today they are essential to
build a more equal and prosperous future
they will guide the Member States in
using the European cohesion money wisely
in the period 20 21 to 27 and of course
we call on the Member States to
translate all these recommendations into
action I think you let me just briefly
say that all our material is now
available outside the press room and
online and without further ado let's
take your questions I saw one from David
David Thank You Anika
David character ideological Italian
radio I would have a couple of questions
I will start in French with Commissioner
Moscow VC monsieur le Commissaire was a
VD color commissioner you said that the
door is open
and now
we'll have the opinion from the economic
and Finance Committee I want to ask you
what should Italy do in order to avoid a
an excessive deficit procedure being
opened does there have to be an amended
budget
yes today the International Monetary
Fund will say that Italian that is a
danger for the whole eurozone do you
agree with that evaluation secondly mr.
Mehta Savini which is the vice prime
minister in Italy is saying that he want
to change stability impact stability and
growth pact rules do you think that it's
possible today to change those rules
thank you
come on say but that power I perhaps
like to start by running through the
next steps just to make sure
everything's clear today after present
time were not in the process of opening
an excessive deficit procedure on the
basis of the debt criteria but this is a
first step we could this could be moving
towards that first step now we have the
report from the Commission that will be
discussed in the EFC the economic and
Finance Committee then by council which
is two weeks to form an opinion that's
what's provided for under the treaty if
the position of the EFC is to support
the Commission conclusions then at that
point there might be an EDP opened but
the Commission would in turn have to
address their opinion to Italy inform
Italy and inform Council as well on that
basis the council might may decide on
whether there is an excessive deficit
and might make a recommendation to Italy
and that then would lead to a procedure
been opened what I would say on that
is that basically the council it will
also be examining the situation and
obviously it's also up to Italy to
provide the necessary information and
it's not a question of us saying you
need to do this that or the other
now we've always said that we're always
ready to have an exchange to have a
discussion on the factual information on
the figures provided by the Italian
government so that's what would be done
now and we need to specify clearly that
the door is open our door is open were
there to listen we want an exchange and
now it's up to Italy to
demonstrate how we might avoid an
excessive deficit procedure in triggered
okay as concerns as a second question
now that was a whole reason why
stability and respect was actually
adopted and why European semester was
introduced it was acknowledgment that
what happens in one GU Member State and
especially in one eurozone member state
affects others so certainly fiscal and
macroeconomic developments in member
states are to extend matter of common
concern and it certainly goes also for
Italy as regards specifically depth
developments you already outlined our
concerns that indeed in a last year's
depth in Italy is not going down
it's rather going up and forecast go up
and we consider that Italy needs to
reconsider its fiscal trajectory put its
public depth and also budget deficit
clearly on downwards pass and it's first
and foremost important for Italy itself
because we see that current fiscal
trajectory already has created damage to
Italy's economy growth has slowed down
currently Italy the slowest growing
economy interest rates how went up it
has negatively affected investor
confidence that's potentially affecting
investment so all those factors show
that there is a need to reconsider the
fiscal trajectory it Italy has currently
chosen
thank you very much had a question from
mark typical let's try to limit to one
question because there's people across
the room trying to ask good afternoon
Mark Baber Corvis condi promised only
one question for the commissioners
Moscovici and Dombrowski's in November
last year
you actually concluded the same that EDP
procedure for Italy was warranted then
in December you aborted the procedure
because Italy shifted some billions
within its budget and especially also
Moscow vision mister Moscovici hinted to
it because you were very afraid of the
effects and EDP procedure might have on
the European elections now we are there
again we we see that in European
elections the populist one leg I went
from six to 34% and Italian government
assure the Italian economy is actually
in worse shape and in December and the
question is looking back so in with
hindsight do you think it was a mistake
stop the procedure last December well as
regards last autumn indeed it was also
our conclusion in last autumn that
opening excessive deficit procedure for
Italy was warranted and it was Member
States when assessing this conclusion
which called a European Commission for
dialogue with Italy and for exploring
the scope for Italy to actually correct
its fiscal trajectory and that exactly
what has been done as a result of the
discussions we had in late last year
Italy corrected its budget deficit for
this year for from forecasted I
emphasize forecasted two point four
percent of GDP to two point zero percent
of GDP of course it was based on better
macroeconomic assumptions of growth rate
of 1.1 percent currently we know that
growth has slowed down much more
considerably and currently the forecast
is only 0.1 percent growth and thus a
budget deficit correspondingly is higher
again it means that in any case as I
said before there is a need for Italy to
reconsider this fiscal trajectory chunky
to Busey well I'll start in French
and after Sam go to cook PF edith piaf
here Jenova criterion i have no regrets
different today compared to last
December now Stoughton the dialogue
between the Commission and the Italian
authorities focused on fiscal plans for
2019 so it was X on T 2019 trap adroitly
plan presented last October presented
perfectly serious non-compliance with
the requirements of the preventive arm
which combined with Italy's prima facie
non-compliance with the debt reduction
benchmark in 2017 have warranted the
opening of a debt based excessive
division procedure however after
intensive dialogue with the Commission
the Italian authorities amended their
2019 budget by no less than 10 billion
euros one must not forget that putting
an end to the particularly serious
non-compliance planned for 2019 the
Commission has considered that the
opening of an EDP was no longer
warranted at that time this was approved
by the council and I think this was
really the right decision to take under
these circumstances the Commission
assessment presented today is different
because it focuses on exposed data for
2018 which were notified in April 19 and
by definition we didn't know those
figures in last December in 2018 as I
said Italy did not comply with the debt
reduction and smark it also did not
comply with the requirements of the
preventive arm and that's why today we
are concluding that the debt criterion
is not complied with and that a dead
base exit visas procedure is warranted
for Italy so two different situations at
the right decision in December and I
also believe to write the pro
today and I will be in The Hague on the
20th of June and to see the Dutch
parliament and expecting a good day a
good drink and a nice discussion I'm
gonna take a question there from Rob
from the Belgian public broadcaster
because I know you have a life in a
minute question for Commissioner Tyson
Belgium is a borderline case according
to commissioner Moscovici does that mean
that a government has to be formed
quickly in Belgium in order to be able
to move away from that danger but a lot
more think about that oh well let me say
that it's always better to have a
government that has the power to act I
mean that's good for the people people
want a solution to the problems and in
order to resolve problems in order to
implement problems and achieve results
you need to take decisions and that's
basically what a government does and a
government can only do that if they have
full powers and so it's important to
have that kind of government that means
that we have a more stable partner for
our talks now last time when we have the
country reports in the spring where we
said yes it was borderline what we're
seeing now is that we still don't have a
have any certainty as regards the
repercussions of certain decisions that
have been taken for example some tax
reforms but Belgium is going in the
right direction in the sense that we're
seeing that they are aiming at the
objectives they are going in that
direction there's a good balance and
unlike some of the other countries the
deficit is still continuing to decrease
as is the debt so the trend it's
structural trend is a going in the right
direction
obviously there's still a lot of work to
be done and it would be good if there
were a full government formed soon but
no one's holding their breath as it were
when we have the history of 541 days
then give the rest of your a bit of a
bit of a chance Tommaso
you
Kalavati lacrimosa Teresa [ __ ] you miss
me if I may it's always in Italy because
I know that it has a lot of problems
should reform itself but I've read that
in a report by an italian danish
economist working in italy the unit
chief economist Eric Nielsen he pointed
out that the Commission gave four
different evaluations of the output gap
of Italy regarding 2017 I wonder if you
think that in the Commission assessment
there might be and a problem of
econometrics when giving for granted
that Italy as a lot of probably should
reform itself etcetera etcetera but
these wide variations of the output gap
which is an important factor in your
evaluation I mean it's quite stunning
thank you so much I'm not going to enter
in too much technicality but since you
raised this issue I need to give a few
estimates the mythology used to estimate
potential output and output gap the
purpose of fiscal civilians was
developed with and by member states and
has proven to be a rather robust for the
years the assessment of member states
fiscal situations is never a mechanical
extrapolation but one indicator the
rules themselves foresee the need for an
overall assessment and some description
to allow for economic judgment the
output gap is as only one part of the
overall framework to determine the
physical requirements and all relevant
factors are taken into account that's
what we did
having said that the output gap
measurements ensure transparency an
equal treatment for countries subjected
rule that the SDP
experts from all numbers typically
discuss scrutinize the
Greek mythology in the output gap
working group of the council to ensure
the economic rationally of the
methodology and possibly introduced
country specific amendments and
furthermore several cross checks with
different estimation methods are in
place to ensure robustness of the
Commission estimates that what I would
say on that not to be too technical I
think that the Commission took into
account all data which was available and
all relevant factors and again we are
ready that's the meaning to exchange
more data if you know three T's said the
basic things about output gap there is a
common methodology there are lots of
discussions about this common
methodology but then it's also for
member states to agree if they decide
and want to change this common
methodology so far this agreement has
been evasive it's not be say so we
applied methodology as decided by member
states but what I really wanted to say
is that here we are clearly beyond if
you want nitty-gritty of output gap we
look at the main macroeconomic
indicators and they are all flashing red
that we really have an issue budget
deficit is a growing public depth is
growing growth is slowing down so there
clearly is a need to correct this fiscal
stance move to this side of the room
briefly we make our way back over here
we go for the echo my question
it's not to do with the one-off on the
CSU it's more CSEE perhaps are mistaken
but my impression is that France has
already used up all of the room for
manoeuvre that they had under the pact
and there's seem to be moving straight
towards an exit ramp as it were
yes well since so you think the question
is in French I'll answer in French yes
it's true that various of the figures
are close to zero which is not in line
with the preventive dimension of the
pact or as regards the deficit procedure
we have to work on ex-post data so data
gone back to 2018 and that's the basis
upon which we made the conclusion that
the criteria were valid
now as to 2019 and 2020 there are other
dates as it were under the rules the
draft budget will be examined in the
autumn and then the Commission will form
an opinion on it and that will be the
current commission structure of funds
20:19 will know about those in spring
2020 and that might establish that
growth is weak but in any event those
things will be established at that point
were not in any way at this stage
talking about an exit ramp er going off
the the highway as it were rather
dramatic terminology but as regards the
structural funds for the next budget
period and as to what whether they will
meet the requirements under the
stability and growth pact we will be
examining that we news entered press
agency she's been waiting quite a while
petrovin will restore Slovenian
newsagency I have a question for vice
president Dombrowski's about Slovenia
first I would like to ask for your
comment on the lack of progress when it
comes to reforms in health care
long-term care and pension system and
second could you please elaborate a bit
on on the Commission's analysis on what
areas should Slovenia focus its
investment policies and why on those
areas thinking okay so first as regards
Slovenia indeed as regards
implementation of countries specific
recommendations in Slovenia our
assessment is that Slovenia has made
limited progress in addressing the 2018
country specific recommendations and
correspondingly some of the topics are
reoccurring also in this year's
recommendations including we have a
recommendation on adaptation and
implementation of reforms in health care
and long term care sectors that ensure
quality accessibility and long-term
fiscal sustainability as well ensuring
long-term sustainability and adequacy of
the pension system so this is in this
year's country specific recommendations
as regards investment areas our
recommendations are to focus on research
and innovation low carbon and energy
transition sustainable transport in
particular rail and environmental
infrastructure taking into account
regional disparities and I would say the
recommendations for a Slovenia are
broadly in line with our kind of general
policy guidance in in in this set of
recommendations and so focusing also on
European priorities
okay good afternoon a little with your
act if a question on in Spain I
understand that today you have to
communicate the the positive news but if
you look at the structural deficit which
will be the crucial indicator under the
preventive arm Spain has the largest
structural deficit around 3% according
to your assessment Spain made nor no
efforts in 2017 and 2018 and based on
the analysis of the stability programme
Spain will be wouldn't reach the target
in 2019 and 2020 so there is no
reference to further measures in in your
assessment you only make a reference to
the council saying that is the council
who calls for more measures so my
question is based on your analysis of
the stability program whether you think
that Spain has to take more measures on
top of the stability program or you are
satisfied with that god
Spain indeed Spain is now moving from
excessive deficit procedure to the
preventive arm of the stability and
respect and as already said in
introductory remarks it means that Spain
would need to continue with sound public
finances and our recommendation is to
ensure improvement of the structural
balance by 0.65 percent of GDP both this
year and next year based on stability
program compliance with a transitional
depth rule is not ensured in 2019 and 20
this is confirmed also by Commission's
spring forecasts so certainly will
continue to follow budgetary
developments and monitor suppose the
measures of the next government but as
regards next steps of formal assessment
of compliance we stood
19 requirements and the preventive arm
it will be carried out exposed in a
spring 2020 we've completed the our
Athanasius
president and the Commissioner it seems
that it's a little bit too early for
Greece to be backtracking already from
commitments risking fiscal discipline
and risking the hiring ceiling in the
public sector by a margin of a thousand
five hundred fifty employees this
constitution I think a political problem
do you agree that the problem is first
of all political and will you say that
the lack of leverage from the European
side is one of the factors that
contributed that they said this SATs
will say early but tracking and the lack
of reform amendment whatever is
happening right now when what's your
message for the next government any next
government after the elections Thanks
well if we want to ensure that Greece
successfully so to say stands on its own
feet and successfully returns to the
market financing as I said in
introductory remarks a room for
manoeuvre is very limited it's a
delicate exercise for Greece to come
back to the market financing with
in-depth public debt around 150 percent
of GDP so there is a very limited scope
for mistakes therefore and resource
outlined in enhanced surveillance report
it's important that Greece continues to
stick with the commitments is has taken
both in terms of post program fiscal
trajectory and as regards implementation
of structural reforms and indeed we
expect difficult discussions concerning
this in June Eurogroup a coffin
mission is not supposed to enter into
politics and so I won't have that kind
of judgment I would just say that if you
look at the past you need to be a bit
more objective than your question
because Greece has made a long way first
to get out of the program and then to
ensure that the reform process is on
track and again if I look and if we look
at the start of this new chapter post
program as I said we must see that it
was globally positive with the battery
surplus for the third year in a row in
2018 with also return to markets which
is progressive with also measures in
order to reduce that and so let's say
that a lot of inmate by the Greek
authorities to sustain the Greek economy
but we also knowledge this report that
there are some delays and that
backtracking is not the right way to
move forward and we need to see what the
effects of any policy which will be led
in Greece in the next month is compliant
with the targets concerning the three
surplus to which Greece has committed
when concluding the program so whoever
founds the next government I will have
to be in that track we will continue to
have a constructive dialogue with the
Greek authorities again whoever runs the
country and the Commission will continue
up in Greece getting to sustainable
economic situation and so if you look at
legacy if you look at the past you need
to up maybe you broader view the future
it's up to the Greek people to decide on
the 7th of July the Commission will
always be there as a friend of Greece
thank you very much Susannah a final
question that I'm able to take
afterwards of course we'll have the
experts in the room have one more
question to our College members okay is
it okay not yet
okay so a question actually on Portugal
cuz you're mentioning here that the
government should improve the quality of
public finances by prioritizing road
enhancing spending so do you think
public investment is disappointing that
the spending priorities are not the
right ones that is that what you mean
and specifically how worried are you
about investment in transports because
you were mentioning here that the
government should focus on rail rail
transports thank you well first of all
as regards a Portugal own fiscal
recommendation in general so it is
recommended that the Portugal achieves
its medium-term budgetary objective in
2020 taking into account allowance
linked to the unusual events for which
temporary deviation is granted and we
also see that their fiscal structure
reforms which need to be implemented or
continued to be implemented and when you
mention this growth enhancing spending
yes it means notably investment while at
the same time there is a need to
strengthen expenditure control
efficiency and adequate budgeting and
also to improve fiscal sustainability of
state-owned enterprises so then as
regards investment priorities itself as
regards a transport so probably are just
not the whole recommendation so it's
once again investment in research and
innovation railway transfer and a port
infrastructure low carbon and energy
transition and extending energy
interconnections taking into account
regional disparities and as you see
already comparing with recommendations I
just
who is Slovenia and it's you could see a
broader set of countries it basically
follows number of European priorities
which are outlined also in our proposal
for next multi-annual financial
framework as regards research and
innovation as regards efficiency of
infrastructure transport energy
infrastructure so we are following
basically the same approach and
substrates the next step on this would
be discussions also as concerns
programming of the EU funding in the
next
multi-annual financial framework I think
to two weeks ago one week ago two weeks
ago a few weeks ago when delivering on
the forecast
one thing that is impressive for the
Commission is that the countries who
have endued a program have now quite
substantial if not impressive
performance as far as growth is
concerned and this is the case also for
Portugal and we must also mention this
good news of course a full recovery
and so long lasting strengths of the
economy requires reforms and that's what
the report is about
footwell not so bad more than this when
left was about to let you go too early
we have one last question from Yahoo
from the Czech news agency in polities
news agency our technology to ask
something which is not directly
connected to the European semester Czech
Prime Minister and republish is using
pretty strong language these days as far
as out it into his alleged conflict of
interest by the euro deters is concerned
he calls the whole thing an attack on
the Czech Republic and the auditors are
incompetent according to him so I know
you usually too
comment ongoing procedures but I would
like to have to hear the vice
president's ideas or feelings or
comments about it thank you
okay so concerning this issues audit
Cory doubt in Czechia in January and
February follows the standard audit
procedure full respect with EU audit
procedures including on spot audits
draft findings and the right of oddity
to be heard we are in a phase of draft
audit findings communicated to the
checkout treaties in a form of draft
audit report and in line with the
procedures checkout artists have been
invited to react to the draft audit
report well as regards Commission
auditors they are professionals who
always carry out their work in an
objective manner in a full respect of
both Commission audit procedures and in
line with internationally accepted
auditing standards the aim is to protect
the financial interest of the EU and of
taxpayers including Czech taxpayers the
Commission always looks for cooperation
and thus remains ready to work with a
Czech government on the matter we look
forward to receiving an answer to the
draft audit report and only after the
hearing from the Czech besides a
commission will finalize its report
thank you thank you very much vice
president commissioners thank you to you
we now have our experts in the room
we'll be able to answer your more
technical questions and we'll see you
again tomorrow thank you very much